السبب الشائع للصداع هو
الجفاف ، لكن إحدى طرق مكافحته
هي استهلاك المزيد من السوائل ، يجب أن تهدف
إلى شرب ثمانية أكواب من الماء يوميًا
وتأكد من إضافة الفواكه والخضروات الغنية بالمياه
إلى نظامك الغذائي مثل
الفجل البطيخ والخيار.
محاربة الصداع من خلال
أبحاث المغنيسيوم تظهر أن بعض الأشخاص الذين
يعانون من الصداع النصفي لديهم
مستويات مغنيسيوم أقل من أولئك الذين لا يتناولون
الأطعمة التي يمكن أن تعزز
مستويات المغنيسيوم وتشمل السبانخ وبذور اليقطين
واللوز وسمك التونة والحبوب الكاملة
للمساعدة في تقليل وتيرة
الصداع النصفي.  ضع في اعتبارك إضافة
فيتامين ب للمكمل الغذائي المعروف أيضًا باسم
الريبوفلافين إلى نظامك الغذائي ، يمكنك أيضًا تناول
المزيد من الأطعمة الغنية بالريبوفلافين مثل اللبن الزبادي
وحبوب الإفطار واللحوم الخالية من الدهون
والبيض وفطر بورتوبيللو